hello everyone
and welcome to today's webinar bacterial
mitigation strategies
the fda guidance and implications for
blood centers and transfusion services
i'm alexis carlos of labyrinth and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by bd
to learn more please visit their website
at bd.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want
during the presentation to do so simply
type them into the ask a question box
and click send and we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation
i'd like to now welcome our speaker dr
bayalaski
medical director at american red cross
biomedical services
for a complete biography on our speaker
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen
dr lasky welcome you may now begin your
presentation
hi good morning thanks so much so i just
wanted to
thank bd and lab roots for putting this
together and for having me here today
and for everyone that's joining us today
so i will be talking about the bacterial
uh mitigation guidance that the fda
uh is has put out a little over a year
ago now
um and what its impact will be
to both blood centrist and transfusion
services
and this is probably one of the biggest
things happening
in in the platelet world uh this year
so i just before i start want to say i
have no conflicts of interest to
disclose
and my perspective is that of
a medical director representing the
american red cross
i do have some experience working in
hospitals and
we work with our hospital customers so i
have that perspective
but it is my own uh my own perspective
so the objectives today are to
understand the purpose of the fda
guidance
describe the one-step and two-step
strategies
approved for bacterial mitigation and
then explain
the implications of each strategy for
blood suppliers and
transfusion services so the sga guidance
was finalized in september of 2019
and it was updated in 2020 uh at the end
of
2020 it applies to both apheresis
platelets
and whole blood derived platelets
apheresis platelets being
much more common in this country it
applies to
everyone involved in platelet
manufacturing and transfusion so that
includes blood suppliers
and hospitals and transfusion services
and everyone must be in compliance with
the guidance by
october 1st of 2021
so depending on where
where the manufacturers or transfusers
fall in
in the the life of the platelet
ultimately
hospitals do need to transfuse a
compliant product
even if they are not involved with
manufacturing so there does need to be
a good amount of coordination and
communication between
the blood suppliers what they are
supplying and what how the hospitals are
planning on
meeting the guidance requirements based
on who their suppliers are
so a little bit of background um
due to the room storage uh room
temperature storage requirements for
platelets
they are at an increased risk for
bacterial growth
and therefore a septic reactions more so
than any other blood product
uh you may know red cells are uh
are refrigerated between one and six
degrees celsius
and then we have our frozen plasma
products
so platelets are unusual in that they
have this room temperature storage
uh requirement and
over the various over the uh the last
several decades actually
and there have been various strategies
implemented such as
how we implement donor screening and
deferrals
to how we do the arm scrub
there's something called a inline
sample diversion which means we're
diverting the first 30 or so
milliliters of the collection into a
diversion pouch
and we take that blood and do our
infectious disease screening from that
but so if there was any residual
bacteria
from the needle puncture or even if a
residual
what we call the skin plug that ends up
in the needle that gets diverted
um so as to minimize the the risk of
bacterial contamination into the actual
collection
um there have also been enhancements
made to the bacterial culture process
but despite these efforts the risk has
not been entirely eliminated
so the risk of bacterial contamination
ranges from
about one in two thousand to one in
forty three hundred units
the rate of septic transfusion reaction
due to platelet transfusions
ranges somewhere from one in a hundred
thousand to one in ten thousand units
depending on the method of surveillance
and ninety-five percent of septic
transfusion reactions
and a hundred percent of the associated
fatalities
occur in platelets that are on day four
or day five of their shelf life
now that data is somewhat skewed uh
because
most hospitals have platelets sitting on
their shelf that are in day four and day
five of their shelf life so of course
you're just more likely
to transfuse no no hospital has a
a platelet that's on day one of its
shelf life because it's still processing
so a little bit a little bit uh skewed
but uh
it's still inform informative for for us
to work with
so the strategies include either a
single step or
two-step culture-based method a
culture-based method used in combination
with the rapid tests
and pathogen reduction technology so to
illustrate the process
the graphic at the top left shows an
apheresis based collection which is the
most common type of collection method
for platelets used in the united states
today
platelets can be collected either in 100
plasma
or with a platelet additive solution
that replaces 60 for
65 percent of the plasma with a saline
based nutrient media
called paths or pas and across the top
the platelets you can see can then be
processed by a pathogen reduction
process this completes this pathway
if you follow the platelets instead down
on the left this brings you to your
different strategies that employ various
combinations of bacterial detection
methods
the first is called lvds this stands for
large volume delayed sampling and what
this means
is that first of all a certain number of
time must pass before taking the sample
and this is to ensure that if any
bacteria are present they have
sufficient time to grow to detectable
levels
and additionally a larger volume of the
platelet collection is sampled
also ensuring a sufficient number of
bacteria are present to be detectable
and so alternatively a primary culture
can then be followed by a second culture
a few days later or a primary culture
can be followed by a rapid test
so let's look a little closer at how
these methods can be used
alone or in combination so
a lot going on here but i'll walk you
through this over on the left
you see the one step strategies at the
top we see
first is pathogen reduction this has to
be completed
within the first 24 hours from
collection
and these platelets have a five-day
shelf life currently
the next one-step strategy is called
lvds
36. so the requisite
for this is a minimum of 16 milliliters
which includes eight mls for an aerobic
culture and eight mls for an anaerobic
culture
are obtained from each split before i
elaborate on that i just wanted to
clarify what that means how this is
different
from how we have already been
performing our bacterial culture because
this bacterial
culture process the the basics of it are
not new
um the the new components are the volume
what you're sampling and how long you're
waiting before it's sampled so the
previous process
we were taking eight to ten mls um
for aerobic and anaerobic from the
mother bag
meaning you know they're our original
collection that we've collected from the
donor we just have to sample that
first um and then that
whether that gets distributed as a
single unit or then can be
um divided into a double or a triple
we've we were only sampling that initial
bag
and also time wise we were waiting for
24 hours
after collection to sample it so now
what's different with the lvds
is that we have to sample each daughter
bag so they get
split first and then that those eight
eight eight ml aerobic animals anaerobic
are taken from each bag
and so you can see if it's a single
it'll be the same but if it's a double
or a triple we are now sampling
up to three times as much as we were
previously
and for the lbds 36 you have to wait
for 36 hours before you sample it and
then for the lvds 48
you have to wait 48 hours after
collection before you sample it again
that's to
provide the bacteria if there are any
bacteria present enough time to
proliferate
to a a degree that are detectable
so going back to our strategies over
here
we see um back to lvds 36 so that's the
middle option on the left the sample
will be put onto a bacterial detection
device and then after that it will be
will be held for an additional 12 hours
before the associated units can be
released of course the release is
assuming that the culture is negative at
12 hours
and then the culture bottles actually
remain on their instrument for the life
of
the product so for the life of the
platelet and a notification to the
hospital
will be made if at any point the culture
alarms positive
so these units have a five-day shelf
life and then the final one step
strategy is
lvds 48 which is similar to the lvds
in that the samples must be drawn from
each split
the difference being that the
collections are allowed to sit for 48
hours
prior to sampling and the samples put on
a bacterial detection device that will
be held for an additional 12 hours
before the associated units can be
released
and these product tabi's shelf life of
seven days provided that the storage
container is fda approved
for seven-day storage so there are some
uh bags from different manufacturers
and some culture or not culture
the collection media that are approved
some are not so of course that
depends on whether the actual um
kit has been approved for seven day
storage
and then over on the right we have the
two step strategies so the first step
is a culture-based method where the
sample is drawn at
24 hours from collection and held for 12
hours
so this is describing what what has been
currently in place so that
in and of itself um
you are you can be used up to day
three so we are
we are not doing the delayed sampling as
we are with lbds36 or the lbds48
and we're only sampling from the mother
bag so it doesn't have the large volume
uh so again this is usable up to day
three as is though the intent of this is
really to
do additional testing on it so if you go
down to
the next box step two we see that you
can do
a secondary culture on day three or
later
and you only have to do an additional
eight milliliters for an aerobic medium
and this has a five-day shelf life
and then uh if the second culture is
performed on day
four or later the unit now has a seven
day shelf life again provided the
container is approved for 70 storage
i wasn't keeping up with myself here
okay so and then you could actually take
the lvds 36 with a five-day shelf life
and perform a second culture on it on
day
four or later and turn it into a seven
day product
and alternatively you can take any one
of these
and instead of doing a second culture do
a rapid test
as they as the second test or the second
step of a two-step strategy
and the unit that has already undergone
primary culture
can be sampled using a rapid test at the
time of issue
up to a maximum of 24 hours prior to
transfusion
and i will elaborate on the process of
each of these
in a few slides but i wanted to take a
moment and explain uh what is a platelet
storage lesion
it's the combined effects of the
biochemical structural
and functional changes due to the
collection process
the storage of the platelets the room
temperature environment and the constant
agitation
so the collection process exposes the
platelets to centrifugal sources
and during collection and storage the
platelets are exposed to artificial
surfaces
both of which result in platelet
activation
fragmentation lysis and release of
biochemically active substances
room temperature storage facilitates
continuation
of the platelet metabolic processes
resulting in
glucose depletion which in turn causes
lactate accumulation which causes a
decrease in ph
so you also see impaired atp generation
which reduces the capacity of the
platelet to perform
processes that require energy and the
platelet also undergoes alterations
in its surface proteins which results in
a decreased platelet aggregation
so this is a nice graphic that
demonstrates what i just described and
it shows
some of the biochemical mediators of
these processes
the end result being decreased platelet
function
and decreased platelet survival
once it's transfused so what does this
mean
clinically well corrected count
increments
and post-transfusion platelet recovery
and
survival were found to be superior in
platelets stored between zero and two
days
versus five to seven days so corrective
count increment
uh is how much
uh is a platelet unit increasing the
platelet count in a certain
patient and so what's taken into
consideration is
the is how many platelets are actually
in the unit
um as well as the size of the patient so
if you have a
one unit that with a certain number of
platelets going to
a small person or a child we should
expect to see an increase
uh in a higher increase in the number of
platelets
because you're just giving them more per
pound and
versus if you give that same unit to a
larger person
so this is um but it is also
not only is it dependent on the person
but it's also dependent
on how viable the platelets are
themselves so if you have
platelets that are old and not
functioning very well and
you may not get as good of a bump um in
in the count and they may not last as
long
while they're circulating in the patient
and of course that's important because
if they're not lasting as long in the
body
then in the and you have see a cancer
patient
who needs platelets often you might be
needing to transfuse those platelets
um more often if you have a shorter
survival time
so these are important indicators of
the um of the platelet function and some
things that when
when there are studies being carried out
to look at
what different types of modifications
are performed on platelets
these are the measures or the indicators
of how well the platelets are surviving
whatever that processing is so
platelets produce better outcomes in
in recipients when they're stored
between zero and two days versus five to
seven days so in other words
that the storage process the age of the
platelet
impacts has a negative impact on
um their ability to do what they do once
they're transfused
so there are a number of studies that
have shown very mixed results
when it comes to transfusion interval
meaning
how often do you need to transfuse do
you need to transfuse every day every
second day every third day
and mixed results regarding bleeding
events
so platelets are transfused to prevent
bleeding
so if you are still having bleeding
events that means that they're not
working as well
so that would be and the rate of of
bleeding events would be another measure
of how well your platelets are working
and then of course rates of sepsis uh
you know depending on whether you have
fresh platelets versus older playlists
again the older platelets uh
having an increased risk of producing
sepsis
so the the overall
conclusion of this particular paper was
that there's insufficient evidence to
discern the effects of platelet storage
lesions on safety
on transfusion safety due to equivocal
data
and and this is really due to small
cohorts
observational protocols and really just
a lot of heterogeneity and outcomes and
really what we need
is randomized control trials to really
hammer this out
but like i said some of the um the
initial studies that show
platelet recovery and survival would
would suggest that
older platelets are not as good
okay so and i will get back to that in a
second
um there are no studies really that
quantify the relative risk reduction of
each strategy
option however in 2020 the university of
utah published the results of a
simulation study
that compared the various culture-based
strategies
over a variety of hypothetical
contamination scenarios so this is
only comparing the culture-based
strategies it's not
incorporating the pathogen reduction
technology and it is not
touching on the rapid test so
over on the left you see a bunch of
codes
it's really pretty simple actually the
first number represents the hours
post culture when the sample was
collected so 24c
means a sample for culture was drawn at
24 hours post collection 36c
means the sample was was uh collected
for culture
i'm at 36 hours and so on and then the
last number
represents the final day of the unit's
shelf life so if a culture was drawn at
36 hours
it will have a shelf life of five days
so all of these different
codes you can match up to the different
products
based on the the one step and two step
strategies that i
showed you in terms of lvds 36 lbds48
primary secondary culture and so forth
um and okay so we have the first
uh the first three are the one step
strategies
and the second set are the three options
with secondary cultures
and the final three i misspoke a moment
ago the final three are the primary
cultures followed by the rapid test
so the rapid test is included in here
this just does not include
um the pathogen reduction technology
and the options are all ranked from one
to nine
one representing the lowest risk sorry
did i say one
one representing the lowest risk of
exposure of bacteria to the recipients
and nine representing the highest risk
of exposure bacteria to the recipients
so when the bacteria are present at 10
to 10 to the three and ten to the six
colony forming units so that's just a
way of um
quantifying how much bacteria you have
in a sample
the seven day unit with only one step
without a secondary culture
or test performed on it ranked the worst
in terms of the risk to the patient
and i'll get back to this in a second as
well so two different factors
and that we're looking at here for when
we're talking about the age of platelets
is how well they ate the the platelets
work
and what our risk for bacterial
contamination is
and so this slide shows basically what i
just described
with green being favorable and red being
unfavorable in terms of
level of theoretical risk now this is
just a simulation
and simulations are predictions and not
fact or evidence
but it is based on what we know about
how bacteria grow
and it may be informative for uh you
know what kind of
studies we might want to carry out to
start to look at you know the the
effectiveness um because ultimately you
know we want to be transfusing a safe
product
okay so i'd like to look at these
options a little differently and that is
in terms of availability
so seeing these options on a timeline
might give you a little bit of a
different perspective
up here at the top you can see the one
step strategies
and because pathogen reduction must be
performed within the first 24 hours
it's actually ready for release the
earliest
uh this uh next one below that is the
lvds 36
is available by the end of day two and
the lvds 48 is available to ship
by about three and a half days after
collection
down below we see the secondary culture
choices
are going to be available quite a bit
later because remember the five-day
product
has to have the second culture performed
no earlier than day
three and the seven day product has to
have the second culture performed no
earlier than day
four so this does raise concerns about
the product
developing storage lesions which i
explained
back a while back so it it sounds like
you know it's a little bit of a
misconception to say oh a seven day
product because that's great because
you know we're always struggling with
inventory because of that five-day shelf
life
you just you have no there's no feast
right if you have the feast and famine
there's never a feast right if we have a
face that lasts for like a day and then
it's
expired already so we're mostly it's
either we're okay or we're in famine
state
um because they expire so quickly so
the thought of having a seven day
platelet is
exciting i would say um but for the
the secondary cultures being performed
on on day four
because you can't do that culture until
day four
you're only getting it out onto the
hospital shelves days five six and seven
so the actual usable shelf life where
it's on a hospital shelf
ready to transfuse to a patient is
actually not longer
and in fact it's quite short so you can
see the secondary cultures
um the available um you can see in the
green bar
that is available for transfusion the
secondary cultures have actually a very
short
usable shelf life and that's going to
impact what
hospitals want to have on their shelves
um
okay so
also while the seven day product like
lvds expires
um later again as the simulation
study suggests we do have a potential
increase in the risk of bacterial
exposure
so we have not only um
not only potentially reduced usable
shelf life for the platelets for some of
the
the two-step strategies but we are
seeing that the platelets are being
transfused
later in their in their life um just in
their
their lifetime which means they may not
work as well and there is a greater risk
of of transfusing a bacterially
contaminated
unit so these are things that the the
hospitals are going to be looking at
for you know for a number of things now
there was this study that
aabb just did um this was conducted from
march 23rd to april 5th
of 2021 this represents the perspective
of 272
hospitals uh which represents about 447
000 units or about 20 of the total u.s
platelet transfusions so with one being
the most important we see high a high
level
of safety and ease of use this is over
on the left
meaning ease of use meaning no
additional
no need for additional actions to be
taken by hospital staff
so they want it to be safe and they want
it to be easy
and that makes sense because blood banks
are busy places
and particularly if it's a busy day they
might have an mtp going on
if inventory is tight and they're having
to triage a lot
or if it's in the middle of the night
and they have a more bare-bones staff
which is very common of course they're
going to want to have something that
they can
get out easily so these are not
surprising and of course
we would hope that safety is is always
at the top
and in the neutral range we see the
number of storage days
not so important i would say if people
knew about storage lesion
that might become a little bit more
important but you know
there's also the we talked about in the
transfusion industry that the best
platelet is the available one so
you know if you have it on your shelf
that's better than giving than having
nothing
um so storage days are less important
and then on the least important end we
see
cost and also how fresh the unit is
so here on the the graphic on the left
shows what products
hospitals have reported they prefer the
largest
portion seen in the blue uh in the at
the bottom
is the pathogen reduction in paths which
is about 49
of hospitals followed by lvds 48
at 17 prt and plasma
at 14 lvds 36
at six and a half percent and then it
goes down from there
okay so let's go through each of these
processes to understand how each of them
works
so culture based testing begins with the
eight to ten milliliters for the aerobic
bottle
and 8 to 10 ml for the anaerobic bottle
from each split
so the bottles are inserted
into a bacterial detection instrument
such as the bb bacter
system and the co2 produced by the
metabolism of proliferating bacteria
is picked up by a sensor that translates
into
a positive alarm obviously bacteria that
proliferate more
slowly will produce co2 at a slower rate
and it will take more time for the
culture to alarm positive
at this time if either the aerobic or
anaerobic bottle
of any of the splits becomes positive
all of the units associated with that
collection need to be quarantined
and if the collection alarms positive
after the unit
has been distributed the hospital will
be notified
and they may or may not have transfused
it already if they
have not they quarantine it
and um if they have
they would notify the the transfusing
physician
that there was a positive alarm does not
mean that that was necessarily
a true positive but this is something
like what the
workflow would go through if we were
dealing with uh an lvds
36 so the platelets are sampled at 36
hours
the bottles are loaded onto the
instrument they're held for an
additional 12 hours
and if at 12 hours they're negative
they're distributed to the hospitals
the bottles in the meantime will remain
on the instrument through the end
of day five if it was in lvds 48
it would be through day seven because
that's the life of that particular
platelet product
uh so if if any if at any point it
becomes
negative there are there's sorry
if it comes back positive if it's
negative great we're done
if it comes back positive for any of
those we will do
repeat testing on the original unit and
retrieve uh the retrieved units if they
had been distributed already
and we can determine hopefully uh if
that was a true positive
if it was a false positive either due to
the the sensitivity of the instrument
or due to a sampling uh
qc um you know where the bacteria
were introduced at the time of sampling
into the bottles
or if repeat testing cannot be done if
the units are not available it might be
might result in indeterminate
so a system like this would qualify for
both the lbds
36 and the lbds48 single step options
and it would qualify as the primary and
secondary cultures
also in the two-step strategies
so i just wanted to take a step
aside and talk about
the red cross presented a study showing
the rate of bacterial cultures before
and after anaerobic implementation
now part of the guidance is to include
an anaerobic culture in addition to the
aerobic culture
and this is something that the red cross
implemented early so we implemented this
in 2019
so we have a little bit of experience
with this already and so this
um this was performed without
implementing
the large volume delay sampling strategy
this is just
collected at 24 hours from the mother
bag
as i described a few a few slides back
and so these were the results and you
can see the rate of true positives
went up from this is rate per 100 000
donations
uh went up from 22.7 to 39.6
uh which is of course great for patient
care and
our priority but you can also see that
the total of false positives
on the second line
and then you see so you see false
positives due to contamination
false positive due to instrument error
indeterminate and then
total false positives so the total false
positives went
up from 47.5 up to 198.2
which does impact inventory availability
because those units are lost and by the
time we are able to determine that it's
a false positive the unit has expired
and there's also a lot of back and forth
between uh
performing the follow-up cultures
communicating with the hospitals
retrieving the units
so of course it's in it's for safety so
you know i'm not saying that that's
necessarily a bad thing
but that is something that has to be
considered
as how it will impact uh
platelet inventory so you know the
guidance
the fda guidance in in the name of it is
addressing both safety and availability
so that's something that we do have to
consider as a blood supplier
uh that you know if if we are
going to be collecting platelets and we
know that there's a certain amount of
false positive we have to take that into
consideration with how we're going to
collect
um to to account for those losses
okay this shows the distribution of
anaerobic bacteria on the right so not
only did the number of positives
increase but we can see that it was
largely due to more anaerobes being
picked up
so for the true positives we see prior
to anaerobic testing we had
95 aerobics and after anaerobic testing
was added we see
of the 170 positives only 23 are
aerobic 100 are anaerobic and 51 had
both types and finally
what really matters is how it affected
the patients who were transfused
we saw a total of 10 units from eight
donors transfused that resulted in
septic transfusion reactions
and post anaerobic testing we had two
cases from one unit
so clearly increasing the sensitivity
obviously has a positive
impact on patient care so some of the
considerations for bacterial testing
for blood suppliers we have to think
about how it's going to impact
the fact that we're sampling at larger
volumes
will impact how we can split those units
so
if some if a certain volume was able to
be split into three units
the fact that we have to take more
volume might mean we only have
two units from that so we're going to
have to make up for that deficit with
with increased collections
uh sampling at a delayed interval for
the 36 hours if we were sampling at 24
hours before and now we're sampling at
36
you can imagine that 12 day shift means
whatever was happening at 8 00 am
is now happening at 8 pm and that has
really
significant impact to staffing to
workflow
to delivery schedules to hospitals to
our courier routes
so these are a lot of things that we've
had to take into consideration with
from the blitz supplier perspective
which options we want to choose
of course for true positives we have the
hospital notifications
and the recall of products for false
positives we have impact to product
availability
and inventory levels of course cost is
is worked into that and then for the
implications for hospitals and
transfusion services
again the sampling at the late interval
if it's something like the lvds 36
that the impact it might impact them in
terms of the time that they're getting
their products
and if they were getting them on an am
route they might be getting them on a pm
route now
whether they're transfusion ready or not
depends on if hospitals have in-house
testing
and some hospitals have chosen to either
do the
secondary culture or the rapid testing
or they might have in-house
manufacturing they have in-house
manufacturing it's probably easier to
to uh to pivot and if they don't
and they want to implement these now
they have an impact again to their
staffing how many people they have on
if they need more ftes how that training
is going to work how the workflow is
going to work
um and of course if there are any false
negatives
um that just have an impact to patient
safety okay
moving on to the rapid tests so this
guidance allows for any unit that has
undergone primary culture to undergo a
rapid test as its secondary test
this is the rapid test by vrx called a
variox but called pgd prime and this is
what the cartridge looks like
windows 1 and 2 are where the samples
are placed
a large window on the right is where the
results are shown it basically works
like a pregnancy test you put
the drop of your solution along with the
platelets
and some magic happens inside and then
you get your results
there's one side for the gram positive
one side for the gram negative
and then all the way at the right is
where the control bar shows you
where your test is working the pgd
stands for pan genera detection
and the reagents target that the
lipotechoic acid in the cell wall of
gram-positive bacteria
and the lipopolysaccharides in the cell
walls of gram-negative bacteria
the process requires a sample of 160
microliters of the unit to be transfused
which is mixed with two reagents a
combination of which
is placed into window one and then an
additional reagent is added to window
two
so if we could look inside the cartridge
we would see that this is a sandwich
elisa
and this graphic illustrates the gram
negative strip so
up at the top you see that where the pad
where the sample is dropped
there are co gold conjugated antibodies
with the specificity towards the
lipotychoic acid or the
lipopolysaccharides
start moving to the right and if they
find the bacterial target the binding
occurs
and the complex continues down the road
to the capture line
where the labeled bacteria are trapped
and the signal is produced
this is considered a moderate complexity
test
so that may impact what can be done at
what level
uh what level of complexity the lab
staff
are are qualified for
and this does not need to be repeated
every day it just has to be performed
within 24 hours of
transfusion so it can be used on a unit
at the point of issue or some
transfusions may
choose to batch the test the testing of
many units at once
so a point of issue
might make sense except that you have to
wait
10 to 20 minutes for the test to result
so if you're doing that for every unit
as it's ordered that might not make
sense
um so the batching is fine but if you're
batching them all at say midnight
and that test is good as long as the
unit
is transfer transfused within 24 hours
and if it's not used then the testing
has to be repeated
so if you batch test and then any of
those units
that were tested were not used in a
24-hour period
you would need to repeat the test so the
test can be repeated as many times
as necessary in the plateless life
the unit does not require relabeling if
the test is being used
only as a secondary test on days four or
day five
the unit of platelets does require
relabeling if the testing is being used
to extend the unit beyond
day five to day six or seven because a
five-day
platelet is a different product than the
seven day platelet
so using this test for day four day five
is just meeting the guidance
as a secondary test and this is not
considered a manufacturing step
so the transfusion service does not have
to be registered with the fda as a
manufacturer
however the hospital does have to notify
the the fda of the intent
to extend the shelf life from five to
seven days
so um not all containers
are approved for seven day storage so
this
is not universal you cannot be
universally applied
and it depends on whether it's collected
on a trema versus an amicus so the
manufacturer
kit um whether it's in plasma or paths
the concentration of the the unit itself
and then it cannot be applied to pr
platelets
there was a study and commentary uh
performed by verax themselves reporting
a an out date rate of about
16 um this was a survey of institutions
responsible for
around 21 to 22 percent of the annual
volume of platelet transfusions
and for hospitals who were implementing
the pgd test to extend platelets to
seven days
resulted in a savings of around 24 000
units of platelets
which means an outdate rate reduction of
74
update meaning it's expiring before the
platelet is transfused
reduction by 74 percent and mean cost
savings of around 176
000 on the flip side
of this the red cross red cross
published a study on units that were
tested by pgd
at hospitals who then returned the
products to the red cross for additional
testing
uh 10 mls were sampled from the returned
units and were either cultured
by the red cross or the hospitals
themselves and if the culture was
positive it was considered a true
positive the culture was negative
the initial pgd result was considered a
false positive
and there were some units that couldn't
be retested and so that was left at
indeterminate
now the package insert instructions
state that units that are initially
positive by pgd
should be retested with two additional
pgd tests
and if the subsequent two tests are
negative it's okay to transfuse so
basically a two out of three
now some hospitals chose not to do this
because they felt uncomfortable
transfusing a unit that was ever
positive
so even if they had to set subsequent
negative tests and that's
understandable um what that means is
that the
the test results are a little bit skewed
because
it wasn't exactly per manufacturer's
instructions
but that's because again the hospitals
didn't feel comfortable
um with any positive result if it was a
transfused product
so the results over the the follow-up
cultures over a six-year study period
showed
a true positive rate of 1.6 and a false
positive rate of 86
so this would suggest that there is a
potential uh potentially
significant loss of product both due to
product retrievals
and due to loss of units collected while
the donor is deferred so when you when
you're working up
the the
[Music]
contamination that donor is is on a
deferral so they can't come back to
donate
until the the workup is complete
and the cost of just the secondary
workups totaled
approximately uh 90 000
per year a couple of
caveats to the results the study was
performed on verax's previous pgd test
cartridge
not the pgd prime and like i said the
um the manufacturer's instructions were
not
followed precisely because had the
hospitals performed the two additional
tests this would have
presumably presumably decreased the
false positive rate
so some considerations for rapid testing
and
for blood suppliers the unit must be
transfused within 24 hours of a negative
result
so for a blood supplier this would be
really logistically complicated
it would be different if if you had
we're dealing with a hospital-based
collections program and manufacturing
where
all it would all be in-house uh for us
we we wouldn't it was a blood collector
we would not want to
issue really a 24-hour unit
um or if you know if the if the
test could be repeated they would have
to send it back to us or how would that
work that's really just
quite complicated uh to fit into a blood
supplier workflow
implications for hospital transfusion
services again
might have an impact to staffing
training and
workflow it depends also if they're
using it as a second step
versus extending to seven days and this
has actually
had significant benefits to hospitals
who are in remote locations
who might get snowed in and there are no
platelet trucks
coming in so being able to extend that
unit to seven days
has been quite helpful to some to some
hospitals
or hospitals with small inventories this
may have helped them
again it would also have different
implications for a
batch versus point of issue and then
like i described there are restrictions
on
use now moving on to
pathogen reduction technology so there
are three different
technologies using different different
compounds and different
light sources amitosalin
plus uva is the one used with by
intercept
uh intercept by cirrus which is
currently the only fda approved
past reduction system it was approved
for use in europe
back in 2002 and was first implemented
in switzerland in 2003
so we do have the benefit of over a
decade of safety and efficacy studies
before it was fda approved in 2014
the most important difference between
prt or pathogen reduction technology
and culture is that prt is a proactive
approach
that prevents bacteria and other
pathogens from replicating
while culture is a reactive approach
which relies on proliferation of
bacteria
to a level that can be detected by
testing platforms
so with regard to infection transmission
uh hemovigilance programs have
demonstrated no reports of bacterial
transfusion transmitted infections
or sepsis related fatalities due to a
failure
of pathogen reduction though this does
not rule out
post-processing bacterial contamination
and additionally there have been no
reports of
transfusion-associated gvhd
graft versus host disease which i will
explain further in a few slides
so the way the process uh works is like
this at the top you see this small red
bag
contains a pre-dosed amount of
amitosalin which is added to the
platelet collection
the platelets are then placed into the
illuminator where it's exposed to
uv light for six minutes and after that
the platelets are introduced
to the compound absorption device or cad
for four to sixteen hours which absorbs
out all the residual amitosan
amitosalin and this entire process must
be completed within the first 24 hours
from collection amitosalin
is a synthetic thorolin sorulins are
naturally occurring compounds found in
foods like citrus fruit and celery and
they have natural antibacterial
properties
so when the amitosalin is introduced to
nucleic acid strands it docks between
the pair
the base pairs and upon activation by
the uv elimination
the base pairs crosslink preventing
replication and transcription
so that means this works on anything
with nucleic acid
what this means is that it not only
works on the gram-positive and
gram-negative bacteria
which meets the fda guidance on
bacterial mitigation
but it also works against enveloped
viruses like hiv
hep b hep c west nile virus zika virus
cmv
it's also effective against spirochetes
like those causing syphilis and lyme
disease and protozoa like those causing
malaria and babesiosis
so we have coverage against all the
pathogens we test for
and some of the pathogens we don't test
for
there are surcharges with each
additional test so this potentially
reduces some of those costs
um which would definitely be an added
benefit over time
i mentioned cmv because it can be a
virus of concern
and once an individual has cmv they
become a carrier and it's not an
issue for most individuals with an
intact immune system
but there are certain populations who
are vulnerable to a more serious disease
including death if they are themselves
negative and are exposed
so right now we have two options cmv
seronegativity
which we call cmb negative and that's
when a donor does not have the igg
antibody to cmv
so we are presuming they have not been
exposed or cnv safe
which means leuco reduced and because
cmv
resides in white blood cells when a
product is leuko reduced the chances of
a white cell carrying cmv is
dramatically reduced
the data have shown these two to be
quite similar in their ability to
prevent cmva
transmission via blood and you can see
here
down below when one might be preferred
over the other
but because pathogen reduction
technology has the ability to act on cnb
this really precludes the need for
either of these
that doesn't mean that these are going
away but again it just
provides an additional layer of safety
a big appeal of prt is that pathogen
reduction in technology preemptively
targets
emerging pathogens now we have just
experienced the emergence of a novel
virus
which fortunately was not a bloodborne
pathogen but hiv
and hepatitis b were being trans uh
transmitted in blood transfusions back
in the 80s
before we even knew what they were or
how to test for them
another bloodborne virus that emerged in
the last decade was zika virus
and we had to go through a period of
figuring out how best to screen for it
whether whether it was developing the
right tests asking the right screening
questions
and this is a process that we have to go
through every time a new virus appears
so the fda released a guidance requiring
that zika virus transmission be
mitigated
and offered two options one was to
perform nucleic acid testing
and the other was to apply a pathogen
reduction technology to the blood
so we are seeing the fda supporting prt
as a viable solution to more than just
bacterial contamination
now interestingly the fda withdrew this
guidance
on may 12 stating it really wasn't
wasn't a relevant transfusion
transmitted infection anymore
but it does give an example of how pr
is assisting improving the safety of
blood supply
so until a pathogen is determined no
longer to no longer pose a threat
or an effective cure or vaccine is found
pr can provide a protective measure for
patients
along with providing savings and testing
and blood processing expenses
speaking of re-emerging pathogens this
is from the cdc website showing
first on the left how effective this
country had been
at decreasing the rate of syphilis since
the 1940s
and unfortunately on the right showing
how in the last decade we have been
seeing a significant uptick in cases
and syphilis is something that we do
test for in
the blood and these are statistics from
the cdc website
website showing a dramatic increase in
stds across the board since 2015.
um blood collectors only test for
syphilis which has increased by 74
percent
and what's important to note here is
that all stds uh
increase the rate of hiv transmission so
of course we continue to test for
syphilis and hiv
but it's reassuring to know that both of
these pathogens
are inactivated by pathogen reduction
technology so remember that prt targets
anything with dna
which means prt is also affected against
t lymphocytes
so this makes prt a viable alternative
uh to gamma or radiation for for the
prevention
of th vhd or transfusion-associated
graft versus host disease and the abb
has a standard describing that blood
banks must have a policy to prevent the
hd
and it includes either irradiation
or pathogen reduction as effective
methods
to achieve this prt actually inactivates
lymphocytes
more effectively than traditional
irradiation you can see
in this top graphic that gamma
irradiation disables dna replication
by causing strand breaks at a rate of 1
in 37
000 base pairs while thorolin
with uva activation induces addict
formation in a rate of
1 in 83 base pairs and this technology
has been fda approved for the prevention
of th bhd
so why is this important thvhd is a very
serious consequence
of blood transfusion in certain
susceptible individuals and it can be
fatal we have over on the right the
orange triangle
represents the blood recipient's tissue
and the yellow
pacman cell represents the lymphocyte or
white blood cell in the donor blood
because it's a white cell and its job is
to attack foreign tissue
it still does that even when it's in the
recipient's body
usually this is not a problem because
the number of recipient white cells
far outnumber the donor white cells and
there is an appropriate counter attack
which you see on the bottom left in the
case of an immunocompromised individual
who is unable to mount that counter
attack the recipient
tissues are vulnerable th bhd is rare
uh has it occurs in about one in a
million transfusions but it has a
mortality in the range of
90 to 100 percent so this is something
that
is very important for transfusion
services to
to prevent this was a small study that
looked at transfusing platelets to
hematopoietic stem cell transplant
patients
who are very immune compromised because
their whole bone marrow is being wiped
out
intentionally and the and they propose
that that pathogen reduction
uh technology could be considered a
replacement for
leukocyte reduction bacterial culture
screening
cmv serology and gamma irradiation
with the additional potential benefits
of course of reducing the cost
due to elimination of all of these
otherwise required
modifications all while reducing the
risk of transfusion-transmitted
infections so just a quick summary
pr t is fda approved and also meets the
aadb standards for bacterial
uh the mitigation of bacterial
contamination
it can be used to replace the
need for serologic testing for cmv it
achieves
lymphocyte inactivation for the
prevention of thg vhd
effectively targets bloodborne protozoa
and spirochetes known to be transmitted
via blood transfusion
and has the potential to preemptively
target any yet unknown emerging
pathogens
so some implications for
blood suppliers is that it's
unidirectional processing
it we don't have to go back to it once
once it just moves forward we can ship
it out
um there are guard band requirements
that dictate volume and concentration
um but with pre-collection and
manufacturing strategies to optimize
uh there are no foreseeable losses due
to the pr process
for implications for hospitals and
transfusion services
they are transfusion ready they provide
the freshest platelet earliest in its
shelf life
and they are currently available only as
a five-day product
with seven days anticipating anticipated
pending fda approval and they replace a
number of needs like irradiation
and cmv seronegativity which has the
potential to enhance availability due to
decreased product segmentation
and potentially decreased costs
i know i'm almost at time here here's a
summary of
options uh that i showed you before
just to refresh your memory and
just to walk you through from the blood
perspective let's supply our perspective
why we chose what we chose
um pathogen reduction platelets are our
primary
uh offering because of all of the
benefits that i just described namely
transfusion ready
and delivering the freshest product and
and the
broad spectrum protection against uh
pathogens beyond bacterial mitigation
and then lvds 36
also because they are fresher than the
lvds
48 or some of the other seven day
products
and with that and here's a link to the
complete guidance
i have provided my references here
and i thank you very much i think we
have a couple of
minutes for questions and i would
encourage you i've made my email address
available if you have questions on this
i know i covered a lot of information
please feel free to contact me directly
and i will hand it back over
thank you dr lasky for your informative
presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
so if you have a question you'd like to
ask please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
and we'll answer as many of your
questions as we have time for
so dr lasky we do have just a couple
minutes for a couple questions so we'll
go ahead and get us started with this
first one
are all of these strategies performed at
processing centers or at the customer
sites that's a good question
for something like pathogen reduction
technology
and a primary culture those would
definitely be
occurring at a the blood supplier or
blood manufacturer
from there it would depend on how much
capacity the hospitals or transfusion
services
have to perform themselves there are
hospitals that have their own
collections and manufacturing
so they might be able to perform a
secondary culture
uh i would say the the rapid tests are
probably
more suitable for in-hospital use but it
depends
so there would have to be important
communication between
the various blood suppliers and what
they are intending to offer
and what the hospitals can perform to
make sure that all the steps are being
uh appropriately followed
thank you dr alaski our next question is
bacterial endospores included in the
test
that is a good question i
which test would that be the bacterial
culture test
you know um this ion doesn't quite say
which test i'm guessing the pure pr test
uh so no the
the pr is acting on dna so it
is disabling um replication
if there was anything any just kind of
component
already existing in the unit that's it's
disabling dna
um so it's it's preventing them from
replicating and doing what they do
um i would say for the bacterial culture
if that's um
what's being asked again it's looking
for
um metabolic processes of the bacteria
to to generate co2 for it to be picked
up
and for the rapid test it's actually
targeting
the bacteria themselves so i i think
that endospores are not
included in in any of these i'm not sure
i'm not 100
on that thank you dr lasky
and looks like we have
time for one more question so i'm
assuming since
uh bd is sponsoring this webinar that bd
is approved to culture blood products
yes it is
what i was describing with the bacterial
culture
process in that segment was illustrating
how
the the bd instruments and testing
process
would work and how how it meets the
guidance
thank you so much dr lasky we want to
you know thank you again for your time
today
and for your important research we'd
also like to thank lavert and our
sponsor
bb for underwriting today's educational
webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions that we did not have time for
today and those submitted during the on
demand period will be addressed by our
speaker via the contact information that
you provided at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand
laborats will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time bye bye everyone